عافيه يا ابطال
عفيه
احنا بالعشيره عندنا قوانيننا الخاصه
لا لنا علاقه بدوله ولا احد يقدر يوقف
بوجهنا وهذا الشيء مو اليوم مو البارحه
فتحنا لقينا هنا وعمامنا
[تصفيق]
رغم كل القوانين والتشريعات التي منعته
وشددت على المحاسبه بموجبه لا تزال اليوم
كثير من نساء العراق يزوجن قصرا قادنا
بحثنا لمقابله سيده تعرضت لما يعرف
بالفصليه العشائريه الزواج القصري حيث
تطلب فيه العشيره المعتدى عليها من
العشيره المعتديه تزويجهم امراه من بينهم
تسمى الفصليه وبالفعل تم تزويج هذه السيده
واعطائها ثمنا لنزاع العشائري لا علاقه
لها به
ابن عمي يشتغل بالسوق
اتعارك هو ولد بصفه بمحل بصفه بيناتهم
واحد ضرب الثاني ابن عمي يضربها براسه
وماته فصارت عشائر وقعده وفصول فهل الولد
ذاكر رادوا ولا فصليه وحتى مو زواج مثل
العالم انه يعني خدامه
اثنين نسوان وولد
اجوا يعني حتى وجههم ما بيه رحمه
اخذوني ورحت وياهم
فما اعرف شنو حتى كنت صغيره كان عمره 20
سنه ما اعرف شنو منفصليه وحتى اللي ما
اعرف شو اقول لك يعني عشت وياهم انه انا
خدامه هذا ابو فصليه ما عرفت شلون اتصرف
وياهم قبلت بالواقع على مود انه لا اخوه
اخواني ولا ابوي يعني ينقتل